ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC DEBATE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
NEARLY THREE YEARS AGO,
DONALD TRUMP CAME TO OFFICE AND
HE PROMISED PEACE AND PROSPERITY
FOR AMERICA.
AND AS HE HAS DELIVERED.
EVEN WITH THE HEAVY ANVIL OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION TIED
AROUND HIS NECK, THOUGH A
PRESIDENT HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO DRAIN THE SWAMP WITH MASS
SAFETY REGULATIONS, PHENOMENAL
JUDGES, AND A TAX CUT FOR
WORKING FAMILIES.
MARKETS ARE UP, WAGES ARE UP,
UNEMPLOYMENT IS WAY DOWN ACROSS
ALL KEY DEMOCRATIC GROUPS.
ON FOREIGN POLICIES, HE HAS
LIKEWISE BEEN REMARKABLY
CONSISTENT ON HIS PLEDGE TO PUT
AMERICA FIRST.
HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO DO IT
AND HE IS DOING IT.
HE IS MINING ON FOREIGN
ENTANGLEMENTS, LONG-TERM
MILITARY INTERVENTIONS THAT I
SEEM TO RECALL DEMOCRATS USED TO
BE AGAINST.
>> WE'VE BEEN TO WAR FOR MANY
YEARS.
UNNATURAL TO US BUT NATURAL FOR
THEM.
THEY FIGHT.
THEY FIGHT LONG AND THEY FIGHT
HARD AND THEY'VE BEEN FIGHTING
SYRIA FOR A LONG TIME.
AT THE BORDER, THAT IS THE
BORDER WITH SYRIA.
I SAY, WHY ARE WE PROTECTING
SYRIA'S LAND?
THEY ARE NOT A FRIEND OF OURS.
WHY ARE WE PROTECTING THEIR
LAND?
>> Laura: REMEMBER WHEN
DEMOCRATS EMBRACED THIS
ANTI-INTERVENTIONIST APPROACH?
>> THIS WAR DIMINISHES OUR
SECURITY, OUR STANDING IN THE
WORLD, OUR MILITARY, OUR ECONOMY
AND THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
CONFRONT THE CHALLENGES OF THE
21ST CENTURY.
BY ANY MEASURE, ARE
SINGLE-MINDED AND OPEN-ENDED
APPROACH ON A ROCK IS NOT A
STRATEGY FOR KEEPING AMERICA
SAFE.
>> Laura: NOW THAT IS TOTALLY
OUT THE WINDOW.
THE ONLY PERSON ON THAT DEMOCRAT
TO BAKE STAGE WHO, ON THIS ISSUE
REALLY CHANNELED OBAMA.
>> YOU WILL CONTINUE WITH THIS
POLICY OF THE U.S. ACTUALLY
PROVIDING ARMS TO TERRORIST
GROUPS IN SYRIA BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO HAVE BEEN THE
GROUND FOR US IN REGIME CHANGE.
>> YOU CAN EMBRACE OR PUT AN END
TO ENDLESS WAR WITHOUT EMBRACING
DONALD TRUMP'S POLICIES.
>> IS AN ENDLESS WAR?
>> PLEASE ALLOW HIM TO RESPOND.
>> WHAT WE WERE DOING IN SYRIA
WAS KEEPING OUR WORD.
>> Laura: THAT'S NICE, PETE.
BY THE END OF THE EVENING IT WAS
OBVIOUS THAT THE DEMOCRATS WILL
SAY AND DO AT THIS POINT ALMOST
ANYTHING, INCLUDING CONTORT
THEIR OWN VIEWS ON KEY ISSUES
JUST TO OPPOSE TRUMP.
I DON'T RECALL ANY OF THEM
VOICING ANY GREAT CONCERN TO
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN 2012 WHEN
OBAMA DREW HIS REDLINE AND
DIDN'T ENFORCE IT.
THE KURDS WERE STILL IN LOCATED
THERE.
MAYBE IT IS BECAUSE THEY STARTED
SEEING POLLS ON INVADING SYRIA,
AND WHAT WERE THEY LIKE BACK
THEN CUSTOMER CONSIDER WHAT
GALLUP FOUND.
68%, 24% OF AMERICANS OPPOSE
MILITARY ACTION TO ATTEMPT TO
END THE CONFLICT EVEN IF ALL
ECONOMIC AND DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS
FAILED TO END THE CIVIL WAR IN
SYRIA.
HAVE AMERICANS TODAY REALLY
BECOME A NEWLY
PRO-INTERVENTIONIST?
I DON'T THINK SO.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS MAYBE THEY
HAVE, ALL BECAUSE THAT KEEPS
THEM IN OPPOSITION TO TRUMP.
AND NANCY PELOSI'S PARTY
ESSENTIALLY BELIEVES THE
AMERICAN WAY OF LIFE IN MANY
WAYS HAS BECOME EVIL AND
UNSUSTAINABLE.
THE CANDIDATES THINK TRUMP IS A
MENACE AND HE'S GOT TO GO.
OTHER THAN THAT, THEIR POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS ARE KIND OF A
MISMATCH.
BIDEN THINKS IF HE WINS THINGS
WILL MAGICALLY GO BACK TO OBAMA
WITH STEVIE WONDER AND TOM
HANKS.
AS FOR SANDERS AND WARREN,
THEY'VE ADOPTED A EUROPEAN-STYLE
SOCIALIST APPROACH, WHICH, LAST
TIME I CHECKED ON HIM ISN'T
WORKING ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
NOW.
AMY KLOBUCHAR, PETE BUTTIGIEG,
THEY'RE TRYING TO HOLD
THEMSELVES OUT AS MORE MODERATE
AND REASONABLE DEMOCRATS BUT
NEITHER OF THEM CAN GET OUT OF
SINGLE DIGITS IN THE POLLS.
AND BETO, HE'S BASICALLY A LESS
INTERESTING AND LESS INTELLIGENT
AOC.
CASTRO IS A RADICAL,
OPEN-BORDERS NIGHTMARE.
BOOKER THINKS DEMOCRATS SHOULD
JUST BE NICER TO EACH OTHER.
LIKE THAT IS REALISTIC.
THEY ARE ALL THE
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDN
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDT
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDB
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDC
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDU
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDE
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDT
EITHER RUNNING TOBE VICE PRESIDY
HAVE NOTHING BETTER TO DO.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT CNN DID TRY THEIR BEST TO
HELP THEM ALL BY STAYING AWAY
FROM CERTAIN TOPICS ALTOGETHER
LAST NIGHT.
FOR INSTANCE, THERE WAS ZERO
QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE MOST IMPORTANT THREAT TO
AMERICAN LONG-TERM SECURITY.
TALKING ABOUT THAT SMALL,
INNOCUOUS COUNTRY CALLED CHINA.
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES, ALL IN
PASSING.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO TAKE THIS
CROWD SERIOUSLY?
NOW REMEMBER, VOTERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
ELIZABETH WARREN IS THE NEW,
SMART AND SAVVY FRONT RUNNER.
>> MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG, YOU SAY
SENATOR WARREN HAS BEEN
"EVASIVE" ON HOW HE IS GOING TO
PAY FOR MEDICARE FOR ALL.
>> WE HEARD IT TONIGHT, YES OR
NO QUESTION THAT DIDN'T GET A
"YES" OR "NO" ANSWER.
YOUR SIGNATURE IS TO HAVE A PLAN
FOR EVERYTHING, EXCEPT THIS.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR, WHENEVER
SOMEONE HEARS THE TERM "MEDICARE
FOR ALL WHO WANT IT," UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS.
IT'S MEDICARE FOR ALL WHO CAN
AFFORD IT.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
BELIEVE THE ONLY WAY TO DELIVER
AFFORDABLE COVERAGE TO EVERYONE
IS TO OBLITERATE PRIVATE PLANS.
>> Laura: SHE'S GOING TO OUT
NEGOTIATE PRESIDENT XI WHEN SHE
CAN'T HANDLE THE MAYOR OF
SOUTH BEND?
I DON'T THINK SO.
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM THESE
DEBATES I THINK IS GENERALLY THE
FOLLOWING.
THE AGENDALESS DEMOCRATS HAVE NO
CHINA POLICY, OTHER THAN
COMPLAINING ABOUT TRUMP'S
TERRACE, NO COHERENT TRADE
POLICY EXCEPT, WE WILL WORK WITH
THE EUROPEANS MORE.
LIKE OBAMA DIDN'T ALREADY TRY
THAT AND FAIL.
THEY HAVE NO COHERENT
HEALTH CARE POLICY, AND SOMEONE
WANTS TO ABOLISH HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE ALTOGETHER.
WILDLY UNPOPULAR.
BUT IT IS STILL A JUNGLE.
THEY HAVE NO PLAN TO RAISE YOUR
STANDARD OF LIVING, THAT I CAN
SAY.
THAT ACTUALLY KIND OF GIVEN UP
TRYING TO ARGUE THAT POINT.
BUT THEIR ANSWER FOR EVERYTHING
IS TO TAX IT.
IF IT MOVES, TAX IT.
IF IT DOESN'T, TAX IT.
>> I DO THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TAXES WILL
GO UP.
>> FOR PEOPLE MAKING BETWEEN
$50,070,000 A YEAR, THE TAXES
WILL GO UP ABOUT $5,000.
>> WE SHOULD LOOK AT WHAT
GERMANY, FRANCE, AND SWEET AND
STILL, WHICH IS A VALUE ADDED
TAX.
>> WE NEED A WEALTH TAX.
>> SOMETIMES I THINK THAT
SENATOR WARREN IS MORE FOCUSED
ON BEING PUNITIVE.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW IT'S BAD
WHEN EVEN PAY
WHEN EVEN BAY
WHEN EVEN BETO IS SAYING TOO
MUCH OF THE TAXES.
EVEN AT THE ADVANCED AGE OF THE
THREE TOP CANDIDATES, AT TIMES
IT FELT LIKE LAST NIGHT YOU WERE
WATCHING A BUNCH OF 19-YEAR-OLDS
DILETTANTE SITTING AROUND THE
COMMON AREA SHOOTING THE BULL
ABOUT STUFF THEY JUST READ THE
NIGHT BEFORE, SO CUTTING EDGE.
>> THAT MEANS THAT OUR POLE
SOLAR SYSTEM COULD BE LIKE, ONE
TINY ANIME IN THE FINGERNAIL OF
SOME OTHER GIANT
BEING.
WHAT?
>> Laura: IF IT WERE ONLY THAT
INTERESTING.
ON ISSUE AFTER ISSUE, THEY HAVE
ALL BEEN TIED UP IN KNOTS.
THEY ARE DEFINING THEMSELVES,
LET'S FOCUS ON THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE DEFINING THEMSELVES
ONLY THROUGH THEIR OPPOSITE OPPS
ONLY THROUGH THEIR OPPOSITE OPPT
ONLY THROUGH THEIR OPPOSITE OPPO
ONLY THROUGH THEIR OPPOSITE OPPN
ONLY THROUGH THEIR OPPOSITE OPPT
ONLY THROUGH THEIR OPPOSITE OPPO
TRUMP.
THEY USED TO BE AGAINST
GOVERNMENT SURVEILLANCE BUT THE
NOW ADVANCE EMBRACE THE
DEEP STATE'S POWERS.
THESE TO BE FOR BLUE-COLLAR
WORKERS, BUT THEY WON'T SUPPORT
AT THE U.S. AND CA.
THEY USED TO BE FOR GETTING OUT
OF ENDLESS WARS BUT NOW THEY
WANT BACK IN.
THERE IS NO CONSISTENCY
WHATSOEVER, EXCEPT ON ABORTION
AND THOSE THINGS I GUESS.
OBAMA ACTUALLY WAS A SMART
PERSON.
I DIDN'T AGREE WITH HIM A LOT
BUT REALLY SMART.
INCREDIBLY TALENTED POLITICIAN.
ELIZABETH WARREN?
WHAT AM I MISSING?
SHE CANNOT HOLD A CANDLE TO
OBAMA.
NONE OF THE DEMOCRATS THAT I CAN
SEE ON THAT STAGE CAN.
THE DEMOCRATS HATE TO TRUMP.
BUT HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF NOTHING
TO REPLACE HIM.
AND I THINK SMART PEOPLE IN THE
PARTY KNOW IT.
LOOK AT THE NEW STUDY OUT TODAY,
THEIR CALCULATIONS SHOW AT 2020
MAP THAT LOOKS LIKE THIS.
WHEN YOU STEP BACK AND YOU LOOK
AT THAT FIELD LAST NIGHT, ON
THAT DEMOCRAT DEBATE STAGE, YOU
CAN SEE WHY SO MANY DEMOCRATS